planétarium. Mais d'abord pour
nous mettre la table, reportage
de Normand Grandin.
- C'est la deuxième photo
spectaculaire d'un trou noir
qu'on nous révèle, mais cette
fois-ci, le monstre n'est pas
dans une galaxie très éloignée
de nous, mais directement
au coeur de la Voie lactée.
Le trou noir a un nom,
Sagittaire A, et c'est
définitivement le grand patron
de la Voie lactée et de ses
quelque 200 milliards d'étoiles.
ROBERT LAMONTAGNE, Centre de
recherche astrophysique du Qc
- C'est véritablement le trou
noir supermassif central d'une
galaxie qui gouverne un peu la
dynamique générale. C'est un peu
comme dans le système solaire,
c'est notre Soleil qui décide,
n'est-ce pas.
Chacune des planètes a son rôle
à jouer, mais c'est
majorita Soleil.
- Sagittaire A se trouve
à 27 000 années-lumières
de la Terre. C'est un objet
énorme : 4 millions de fois
plus massif que le Soleil.
L'anneau incandescent qui or
autour de lui, c'est de la
matière, des gaz et des astres
qui se consument avant
qu'il ne les avale tout rond.
Mais contrairemene
qu'on pourrait s'en faire,
Sagittaire A est plus un géant
endormi qu'un fauve affamé.
JULIE HLAVACEK-LARire
de recherche astrophysique, Can
- Il y a des trous noirs qui
sont très gourmands, qui vont
engloutir énormément de matière
parce que, à ce moment-là,
il se trouve qu'il y a beaucoup
de matière proche d'eux.
Celui au centre de notre
galaxie, présentement, il n'
pas beaucoup de matière proche
de lui, donc il ne peut pas
engloutir beaucoup;
on dit souvent qu'il est à jeun.
- Derrière l'image révélée
aujourd'hui se trouipe
de 300 personnes, une dizaine
de grands télescopes
interconnectés sur la planète,
l'assemblage de milliers
de photos différentes et
une quantité astronomique
de données.
- Si on regarde l'image,
on a l'impression
un peu flou, mais il faut garder
en tête que c'est une image
agrandie d'une toute petite
région de notre galaxie,
qui correspond à l'équivalent
de voir une balle de tennis
sur la Lune. Donc ce qu'on veut
voir, c'est les coutures de
la balle de tennist.t.t.t.t.t.
- L'étude de Sagittaire A
va permettre de mieux comprendre
l'origine de notre galaxie et
sa dynamique depuis sa forma
il y a 10 milliards d'années.
Dans le futur, les chercheurs
vont également tenter de repérer
certains des très nombreux trous
noirs, plus petits, qui percent
notre galaxie comme un fromage
gruyère.
- Ces petits trous noirs là,
selon nos calculs,
il y en aurait beaucoup dans
la Voie lactée. Il y en aurait
à peu près 100 millions
de petits trous qui seraient
vraiment distribués partout
dans la galaxie.
Donc c'est quand même commun.
- Les trous noirs
sont considérés comme un
des endroits les plus violents
de l'univers. Leur densité
est telle qu'ils aspirent même
la lumière.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Mon